here is a plant that I just picked from
the crack in the sidewalk now it may not
look like much but if prepared properly
it can be transformed into a nutritious
and delicious meal I'm dr. bill
Schindler I'm a food archeologist chef
and director of the Eastern Shore food
lab of Washington College now most of us
go to the grocery store to find our
vegetables but we may not realize is
that the nutritional profile of wild
plants or to most of us leads far
exceeds that of domesticated plants I'm
gonna spend the next several hours
walking around my town my neighborhood
and even my yard to show you where you
can find some of these plants and how to
harvest them then I'm gonna take them
back to my kitchen and show you how to
transform them into some nourishing and
delicious meals let's get to it before
we begin a few words on safety now the
first thing that we need to realize is
that all plants contain toxins but when
we're foraging the responsibility falls
on us to properly identify and
understand the plants that were
harvesting the other thing that we need
to keep in mind is what's happened to
the land on which we're foraging have
people sprayed insecticides or
fungicides or herbicides and if so how
does it impact the quality and the
safety of the food we're trying to
harvest and include in our diets
I'd like to introduce you or reintroduce
you to this plant right here many of you
have seen this growing in waste Lots or
maybe even in your own yards and have
probably tried really hard to get rid of
it often considered a class a noxious
weed in many parts of this country this
is in fact one of the most nutritious
wild edible plants in the world it's
known as garlic mustard and as its name
implies it tastes like a combination of
garlic and mustard now it's very easy to
identify for a number of different
reasons it starts its life off with
these young leaves that look almost like
an arrowhead that are somewhat toothed
later on these leaves turn into a more
heart shaped leaf that are scalloped on
the edge it has this think of seed pods
white flowers of four petals but the
most distinguishing characteristic is
that when any part of this plant is
crushed it gives off an odor that is a
combination of garlic and mustard every
part of this plant is edible the
underground roots can be used as a
horseradish substitute the seeds can be
used to make mustard and the stalk the
leaves and the flowers can all be used
either cooked and sauteed or eaten raw
and really the best thing to do with
this plant to make the most of its
garlicky mustard flavor is to use it in
pesto when harvesting the leaves from
this plant we want to ensure that we get
the most tender leaves possible and we
do this by focusing on the new growth
young leaves at the top of the stalk
here we have a common dandelion these
plants grow in just about everybody's
yards and people work really really hard
to get rid of them but this is just
another example of an incredibly
nutritious and delicious wild edible
plant now the name dandelion comes from
the French dente Lyon which means the
lion's teeth and what that's referring
to are its leaves that have deeply
knotch teeth and the points actually
point back to the center of what we call
a basal rosette see a dandelion it's
just like many other spring plants that
when they first appear in the early part
of the year they send out a whole bunch
of leaves in a circular pattern to
attract as much sunlight as possible at
a time of the year when there isn't that
much direct sunlight now other plants
when the stalk comes up out of the
ground it picks up those leaves and
carried them up the stalk but the
dandelion is fairly unique in that it
always keeps its basal rosette leaves at
the ground the entire time it's alive
dandelion greens are full of high
quality nutrition but they're also a
little bit bitter and that bitterness
fluctuates throughout the year in early
spring like now or later on in the fall
that bitterness is greatly reduced but
in the middle of the summer that
bitterness is at its peak and most
people avoid dandelion greens that time
of year just for that reason
so what chefs will often do is combine
the bitter dandelion greens with
high-quality fat particularly high
quality animal fat because that fat will
cut the bitterness and that's why often
when you see a dandelion green sound
it's often cooked with some sort of
bacon grease or have some sort of a
bacon grease dressing you could also eat
the dandelion flower
well this dandelion flower is actually
not one flower but it's a composite
flower made up of a ton of tiny little
flowers it's sweet slightly crunchy and
you can use it to make wine you can use
it as a garnish for salads or you could
also take this dip it in some batter and
fry it up for a fantastic fritter the
below-ground parts of this plant are
edible as well let me show you
there's two Parts I want us to pay
attention to first are the roots now the
roots by themselves are a little bit too
tough to eat raw but when cooked boiled
or steamed they actually are an
excellent cooked vegetable on top of
that if roasted they take on a flavor
that's just like your roasted coffee
beans and make an excellent caffeine
free coffee substitute in fact during
World War two when there were food
shortages people in eastern North
America used to take thin line roots
roast them to taste like coffee and pair
them with Yelp on Holi leaves
ilex vomitoria stand by putting those
two things together people could make a
coffee substitute that actually not only
tasted like coffee but pack the caffeine
punch that coffee does the other part of
the dandelion in fact my favorite part
of the dandelion is this part right here
between the base of these leaves and the
top of the root this is called the crown
and this is my favorite part because
especially in larger dandelions it is
the most delicious and crunchy as part
of a dandelion and they work really
really well raw and salads okay right
here at the base of this wall at the
base of this hydrant and cracks in the
sidewalk is another common delicious
edible wild plant known as wood sorrel
now this plant has heart-shaped leaves
and small flowers with five petals and
it is not only chock full of vitamin C
but it has a delicious sort of acidic
lemony quality to it now it doesn't hold
up well to heat so it's not great for
cooking per se but it's great for a lot
of culinary applications for garnishing
and to use a little bit of it to impart
that wonderful lemony flavor a word of
caution however wood sorrel a member of
the genus oxalis is one of many plants
with a high oxalate content oxalates are
plant toxins that can build up in our
bodies over time and cause all sorts of
issues from joint pain to kidney stones
so this
plant should be consumed in moderation
just like other plants with high oxalate
contents such as spinach almonds and
potatoes one of the best ways to harvest
this plant is with a pair of scissors
and with these scissors I can trim off
the tops of this plant where they're the
most tender but the entirety of the
above part of this plant is edible from
the stems to the leaves to the flowers
to the seed pods this is one of my
favorite edible plant severence
chickweed and it grows everywhere now
its genus deloria refers to its
star-shaped flowers and those flowers
are super cool they look like they have
ten petals but in fact there are five
petals with really deep cliffs
the leaves are teardrop shape and they
grow opposite on the stem from one
another and when it grows with just the
right amount of moisture and shade it
can grow large succulent stems with just
the right amount of crispy bite to it
the entirety of the above-ground portion
of this plant is that that means the
stems the leaves and the flowers but
when I harvest it I really only want to
harvest the tips because they're the
most tender we can use it raw in salads
and we can even saute it just like
spinach shoots this plant is not only
nutritious but I find it incredibly
delicious in fact when I close my eyes
and eat this I think it tastes a lot
like raw corn
[Music]
here we are on the side of this footpath
at the base of this tree and I'd like to
introduce you to this plant known as
field garlic now field garlic is an
incredible first time foraging plant for
a number of different reasons first its
ubiquitous it grows all over the place
and probably everybody watching this as
some of this growing in their yard
second it's very easy to identify and
one of its identifying characteristics
comes from the fact that it contains a
compound known as Alison which produces
a garlicky onion smell when the stems
are any part of this plan are crushed or
broken now this part above the ground
these stems can be used just like chives
but the part that I'm really after exist
under the ground let me show you what
they look like one of the things I'd
like you to notice is that the base of
this plant are small cloves of garlic
that are growing and separating from the
main part of the plant and this is one
of the ways that it propagates and
that's why this grows incredibly well
and disturbed soils so actually by
disturbing the soil and helping to
spread new plants and also aerate the
soil which is good for it as well this
is the part that I'm after this garlic
at the base can be used just like
regular garlic and culinary applications
and it has a ton of flavor but not the
punch that a lot of garlic actually has
here we are actually in my own backyard
right next to my garden beds and I want
to show you this plant that is a common
wild edible plant that we're gonna eat
that's actually not in my garden bed but
actually on the side of it that is the
common violet the common violet is not
only delicious and nutritious but when
it's in flower is absolutely beautiful
the flowers the Corollas can occur in
all sorts of different colors from
purple to white the leaves themselves
are heart shaped with toothed margins
and have no hair on them whatsoever the
leaves have been used for everything
from reducing blood pressure to aiding
in digestion relieving coughs as a blood
purifier reducing fever treating skin
problems treating cancer and even to
treat hemorrhoids in fact the leaves
contain salicylic acid which is the
principal metabolite in aspirin and not
only that but these leaves are high and
utilized and that's a soluble fiber and
so by consuming these leaves the soluble
fiber not only soothes but acts as a
prebiotic that helps support healthy
population of probiotics in your gut the
leaves can be cooked and sauteed or they
can be eaten raw in things like salads
and the flowers well they can be used as
a garnish that I had a splash of color
and a nice crunch and sweetness to
anything you put it on in just a few
short hours by walking through my
neighborhood my town and even my own
backyard I was able to collect all of
this fresh food now I'm going to show
you how to process it and transform it
into incredibly nutritious and delicious
dishes for the first dish we're going to
highlight the flavor of the garlic
mustard we're going to combine that with
the wild filled garlic will be collected
and make an incredible pesto and we're
gonna use that pesto to combine it with
homemade mozzarella cheese olive oil and
salt to top a long fermented sour no
crust
for the second dish we are going to use
fat to cut the bitterness of the
dandelion greens traditionally that's
done with bacon grease or even bacon but
we're gonna use a different fat we're
gonna take Maribel's
beef marrow bones roast them in the oven
to liquefy the incredibly satiating
nourishing bone marrow on the inside
and then we're going to take and make a
very quick vinaigrette dressing bana
lion greens arrange them around the
roasted marrow bones and serve that with
a long fermented sourdough bread
finally for the rest of the greens we're
going to saute them so Tang is a great
way to take a look any wild green and
turn it into something that you can use
in almost any dish for us we're going to
combine that with homemade ricotta
cheese made from the whey left over from
making the mozzarella we're gonna put
that inside a fresh pasta dough and top
it with an egg yolk we're adding an egg
yolk for three reasons first because it
adds a ton of nutrition second because
it also adds a little bit more fat to
help cut any residual bitterness that's
left in the greens and finally we're
adding the egg yolk to this ravioli
because it transforms a basic ravioli
into something decadent foraging and
provide access to all sorts of unique
flavors and textures that you just can't
get at the grocery store and forging
connect you with the world around you
and some unique and powerful ways once
we realize that these edible wild plants
exist all around us even in our own
backyards and that they have the ability
to provide the highest quality nutrition
possible for plants then maybe instead
of trying to eradicate them we can
actively try to propagate them and once
again return wild plants into our diets
like they've been for millions of years